[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight progressives have always
been angry indignation is their
signature emotion but a year and a half
into the Trump administration their rage
has finally consumed them the left is
spinning completely out of control just
two weeks ago only a few fringe figures
called for abolishing border enforcement
now that's a mainstream view in the
Democratic Party watch ice has strayed
so far from its mission it's supposed to
be here to keep Americans safe but what
it's turned into is is frankly a
terrorist organization of its own we
need to rebuild from top to bottom
starting by replacing ice with something
that reflects look at ice what a group
of incompetence at this point they're
focused more on Toddlers than terrorists
if you should get rid of it start over
reimagine it and build something that
actually works Kirsten Gillibrand and
Elizabeth Warren are thinking strongly
about running for president
they don't take positions lightly if
they're calling for the end of national
borders and that's exactly what they're
calling for they think their party is
with them and they may be right
Alexandria Acacio Cortes is definitely
with them she's the soon-to-be
congresswoman from New York's 14th
district she's a self-identified
Democratic Socialist what does that mean
exactly last week the New York
Democratic Socialist of America issued a
statement of their beliefs quote abolish
profit abolish prisons abolish cash bail
abolish borders abolishing prisons in a
country with thousands of murders every
year what would that look like well you
probably wouldn't stick around to find
out you'd be long gone along with every
other normal productive person and what
was once America refugees from your own
country something like that happened in
Venezuela there are people in our
country working to make it happen here
and suddenly some of them are prominent
in the Democratic Party this is getting
scary if you pay attention it will scare
you you'd think our so-called
intellectual
be working to moderate rhetoric like
this and guide it in a more responsible
direction but they're not instead those
leaders are adding to the cycle of
extremism consider the reaction to the
retirement of Justice Anthony Kennedy
left-wing law professors at prominent
schools are calling for Democrats to
expand the number of seats on the
Supreme Court and pack it with liberals
for a permanent majority Harvard law
lecturer ian samuel wrote the supreme
court with ten liberals and only five
conservatives would actually be quote
incredibly generous to the republicans
Fordham Law Professor Jed Sugarman
agreed with that if this happened of
course the courts legitimacy would
evaporate overnight but they don't care
they would have power forever and that's
their goal their only goal of course
Republicans could pack the Supreme Court
right now tonight they have the power
but everyone knows they won't do that
only the left is embracing extremism
right now progressive mobs threaten
public figures progressive leaders cheer
them on here's Washington Post writer
Jennifer Rubin explaining an MSNBC that
Sarah Sanders deserves a quote life
sentence of harassment from the left for
the crime of working for Donald Trump
watch Sarah Huckabee has no right to
live a life of no fuss no muss after
lying to the press after inciting
against the press these people should be
made uncomfortable and I think that's a
life sentence frankly she has no right
to live a normal life because she
disagrees with me well there's nothing
liberal about language like that it is
pure authoritarianism